hey guys I'm Kristen roast on
valentine's day is almost here that's
why I joined up with wired to show you
the perfect gift for any guy that's on
your list if you're looking for a gift
with endless possibilities the Xbox one
is definitely it not only is it a great
gift for any hardcore gamer but also any
guy that just loves to blow off a little
steam every now and again if you get
this gift you'll definitely be the MVP
of your relationship I will want one for
myself but I already have to if you want
to take your gift-giving game to a whole
nother level then you've got to get your
guy the apple ipad air it's perfect for
the man on the move that loves to have
work and play right at our fingertips
but you know not everyone is easy to
shop for you know the ones they're
always too picky or indecisive that's
what makes the ebay gift card the
perfect gift I mean you'll find them in
select stores or online and when they go
to shop for their gift they'll find the
perfect one every time and they'll have
you to thank for it thanks guys those
are my pics shop heart stay wired and
have a happy Valentine's Day